if you've been watching this channel for
a while then you'll have heard me talk
about overcoming isometrics so
overcoming isometrics are a fantastic
tool you can use to build more strength
and power and control without
necessarily piling on more muscle mass
on the back of those videos i've had a
lot of people asking well how do you go
about programming overcoming isometrics
how many sets and reps should you be
doing how long do you hold it for and
how does it fit into a broader program
so i thought today it'd be cool to take
a look at a example of an overcoming
isometric program used by none other
than bruce lee himself bruce lee was a
fan of alternate training methods and
this is a perfect example of that and
when we get into it we might even see
that overcoming isometrics could have
been one of the key cornerstones of
bruce lee's training and one of the
reasons that he managed to perform such
incredible feats so without further ado
let's dive in
[Applause]
so for those who aren't familiar with
the concept let's take a quick look at
what an overcoming isometric actually
involves basically this is an isometric
type of exercise meaning that you're not
moving through a range of motion so
concentric is shortening the muscle
eccentric is lengthening the muscle
isometric is staying in one place but
still contracting still exerting force
you have your yielding isometrics which
is what many people instantly think of
when you think of isometric systems like
holding weights in position until you
start to fail essentially it means that
you're leaving some strength still on
the table you're not exerting yourself
maximally with an overcoming isometric
the whole idea is that you're pushing or
pulling as hard as you possibly can
against an immovable force so that might
mean loading up a bench press to 200
kilograms lying underneath it and just
trying to push so i thought a cool
example would be this tree branch which
i doubt i can push straight off the tree
i hope not i'll feel bad if i can and
i'm just going to try and push it
as hard as i can
and that's your overcoming isometric and
you hold that position so why is this
useful well essentially with an
overcoming isometric what you're doing
is you're performing a one rep maximum
or as far as your nervous system is
concerned you're performing a one rep
maximum whether you're pushing against
the maximum that you can lift or whether
you're pushing against something you
can't lift you're still exerting force
you're still calling on your body to
recruit that kind of strength now we're
not going to get the same kind of muscle
damage because we're not going through
the range of motion there's no eccentric
phase and we're not going to load the
body with so much weight so it's not
going to brace the core in the same way
or build bone density however we'll get
a lot of the same benefits in particular
when it comes to neural drive because
you're telling your body it needs to
recruit as much strength as possible and
when you push and nothing happens this
sends a signal that you need to get
stronger when you lift weights to do so
you recruit motor units i've talked
about this a lot they contain slow and
fast twitch muscle fibers and depending
on how heavy the weight is you're going
to recruit more and bigger motor units
to move that load then overcoming
isometric what you're able to do is to
practice sending that signal to the body
to recruit as many large motor units as
possible and as you practice this as you
rehearse it you're going to be cementing
the neural pathways that make that
possible you're going to be increasing
your neural drive so that you become
better at recruiting the maximum and
ideal motor units then when you do go
through that range of motion you'll be
able to tap into greater power or at
least that's the idea and there are
actually some ways in which an
overcoming isometric is superior to a
regular one rep maximum or a very heavy
weight because when you perform a one
rep maximum the whole movement lasts
maybe three seconds whereas typically
for an overcoming isometric we're
looking at a contraction lasting six to
ten seconds so that's much longer than
you're spending performing that maximal
exertion at the same time when you
perform a bench press or a squat or a
deadlift with a very heavy load you're
only actually performing a maximum
effort at one point of the strength
curve because there's momentum there's
changes in the lever length i've talked
about all these things before so some
points of the movement are going to be
harder than others however when you use
overcoming isometrics you are exerting
maximum force for the full time the full
six to ten seconds this is a much longer
and more intense example of exerting
maximum strength and the results can be
impressive studies looking at overcoming
isometrics show that they demonstrate
significantly greater activation in the
muscles as compared with max effort
through a regular lift and another very
interesting study looked at overcoming
isometrics on a leg extension machine
and that showed that it could also
decrease co-activation of antagonistic
muscles some old-time strong men such as
maxic talk about how relaxing
antagonistic muscles is one of the keys
to amazing strength this not only trains
your ability to recruit more motor units
during an exercise within a single
muscle it can also help you to better
perform the movement using the
coordination of different muscles and
this is where it's really interesting
because if we look at bruce lee who used
mainly compound lift with his overcoming
isometrics we see the way that he looked
like a rigid board many people question
whether bruce lee was authentically a
powerful fighter whether he'd perform
well in mma for example this is a moot
point though at the end of the day bruce
lee was highly athletic and you can see
that from the way he moves that's why we
still talk about him today he moves with
power and speed and precision and his
whole body moves as one rigid unit
i talked about how strengthening your
core can help with this in a previous
video but it could also come down to the
fact that he'd practiced using all those
muscles together and exerting maximum
force to plug those energy leaks and to
become this one solid unit to move like
one muscle old-time strongmen also use
this technique very commonly especially
for strengthening their grip they'll do
things like trying to bend bars or roll
up frying pans which until you manage it
is a form of overcoming isometric
luckily for us bruce lee kept copious
notes about his training mainly for his
own purposes and thanks to the work of
john little who's certainly the leading
bruce lee archivist we have access to
these through books like the art of
expressing the human body which is a
fantastic book collecting bruce lee's
training notes and advice on building
muscle mobility etc i highly recommend
checking it out but there's one routine
in particular that seems especially
refined and you'll see this talked about
quite often all over the internet and
this one looks like so so it starts with
a press lockout where the bar is above
him and he's doing a military press just
three inches away from his lockout
position then he moves on to a press
start where he's pushing it up from his
chin position then he has a rise on the
toes where the bar is on his shoulders
as though doing a squat and he's going
to do like a a calf raise and you have a
pull where the bar is six inches above
his hips then he had a parallel squat
would get into parallel and try and
squat a weight that wouldn't move then
he'd perform a shoulder shrug where the
weight is now lower down still and he's
trying to shrug it upwards then a dead
weight lift as he called it where the
weight was two inches below the knee and
he try and deadlift it and then he also
had a quarter squat we'll try and squat
from a quarter position to do these bear
in mind bruce lee wouldn't use a really
heavy barbell obviously because you just
crush yourself you can't hold that
position and it be an overcoming
isometric instead what you do is he put
the barbell in the rack use the pins to
set it in place it wouldn't move and
then just try and push or pull against
it so some of you might have spotted a
potential issue here that being that you
don't necessarily have access to a power
rack that you can pin in place or that
if you do go to your gym doing this is
going to get you some really strange
looks fortunately there are some other
ways you can perform these movements one
is to come somewhere like this and then
just find trees and logs that you can
try and pull and lift
or push and
obviously you're going to be a little
bit dependent on what you find on the
day or alternatively you can use a
device such as the isoflow from bull
worker essentially two separate straps
that are easily adjustable
so you can change the length like so
and using these creatively you can
actually create all kinds of different
positions to emulate an overcoming
isometric with a barbell you could even
attach these to a bar the cool thing is
that we know bruce lee from his notes
used to use a bull worker the original
one that you would push together which
you can still get and incorporate into
your training this is a relatively new
thing it's just quite nice that it has
that lineage it's from the exact same
brand that bruce lee used himself
because they fantastic company they're
really cool bunch they've been sending
me these products to try out with no
strings attached which is just awesome
of them find a link to it in the
description down below this isn't a
sponsored video in any way but i do get
a small commission if you buy using that
link so it's a great way to help out the
channel loads of people have asked me
what this is this is just a piece of
metal that came from a flat pack desk we
got another desk i kept this you can use
anything there's a tendency on the
internet for someone to write an article
then everyone else to regurgitate it so
you might be thinking that's the only
overcoming isometric routine that bruce
lee did as we'll see later he actually
did loads and this was just one example
but this is certainly a great example of
what he might have done and i actually
really like this program so one of the
big limitations of overcoming isometrics
is because you're in just one position
you're not strengthening yourself
through the entire range of motion so if
you're using an overcoming isometric
here say with a chain attached to the
floor then that's the only position
where you're going to build strength
there is a spillover of 15 above and 15
below although that's not an exact
science we don't know a perfect number
but it's something like that so if you
were using overcoming isometrics on your
biceps you'd probably want to use three
different positions in order to make
sure you're strengthening the entire
range of motion what bruce lee seems to
have done here is to not think in terms
of individual muscles but in terms of
the full body and if you look at what
he's done he's done positions all the
way down and all the way up it's almost
like he's gone through a kind of clean
where he's pulled the weight up all the
way over his head and he's pushing up as
well and he's doing pushes and pulls at
each position and this is just a really
interesting way to break down the body
and to potentially strengthen yourself
all the way through it baby you better
train every part of your body
it's not perfect however and there are
some limitations to this program one of
the big ones being there's no rotation
in there now in another one of bruce
lee's overcoming isometrics routines
this is another one he wrote for
students he would have them practicing
punches against the wall and talking to
the kung fu genius podcast john little
said the same thing that bruce lee would
also practice punches standing a certain
distance from a wall and then trying to
perform a punch this was helping to send
out the punch faster but if you also try
to put a bit of rotation in there and if
you use a good solid stance then you can
also train those rotational muscles and
learn to exert force through that motion
as well and it would have been really
nice if he included something for his
grip there but he did train his grip an
awful lot in a load of other ways but if
you're doing something similar i'd
recommend throwing in there something
especially for grip training even just
squeezing tennis balls is a great
overcoming isometric workout for your
grip of course if there's a horizontal
push you're looking for one of the
simplest things you can do is just try
and push down a wall or of course a tree
or if it's rotation you want grab a tree
a lamp post or a door frame and then try
and twist your body whilst keeping that
arm locked out and holding yourself in
place so bruce lee would hold each of
these positions for about six to 12
seconds which as i described earlier is
actually what's pretty much recommended
for overcoming isometrics it didn't say
how many sets and reps he did he might
have only done one but the general
advice on this is to do three sets of
one repetition so you're treating this
very much like a one rep max this is
quite intense on the nervous system not
as intense as doing a one rep max but
it's still you need still need time to
recover and you can't do too much of
this or you're gonna burn yourself out
with that said you'll want to rest
anywhere between 30 to 120 seconds in
between each repetition you can see how
your body feels start with a minute
that's a pretty good place to start one
of the big advantages of this kind of
training is that you actually don't
create those muscle tears so recovery
happens much quicker in the long term
and while it doesn't say which days did
that particular routine on we can guess
that it might have been three times a
week because if we look at some of his
other overcoming isometrics routine such
as one he wrote for his students it
actually says to do those on monday
wednesday and friday for example he
might have had another overcoming
isometric routine for those students so
perhaps he's training overcoming
isometrics every day but three times a
week is a really good place to start in
fact two times a week would be fine and
you can do this alongside the rest of
your training because it only takes
about 15 minutes if that so there's
nothing to stop you doing this at the
start or the end of a workout
immediately after doing overcoming
isometrics you might benefit from post
activation performance enhancement or
post activation potentiation two
slightly different concepts but each of
them results in you being slightly
stronger because you're able now to
recruit those motor units more quickly
they're kind of fired up and ready to go
and you've just rehearsed that movement
pattern so if you perform an overcoming
isometric deadlift for example just once
you might then find it's easier to
perform a normal deadlift with a heavy
weight straight afterwards it's like
contrast training essentially like doing
heavy barbell squats followed up by box
jumps for example there are a bunch of
other uses for overcoming isometrics as
well you can use them for example to
overcome sticking points so if you have
a particular point in a range of motion
that you find difficult if you
constantly get stuck in the same point
in a squat or a bench press then
performing an overcoming isometric at
that point can help you to strengthen
yourself there because that's exactly
where you're exerting the strength
likewise it can be fantastic for
rehabilitation and for remaining strong
when you're recovering from an injury
because there's no range of motion
there's no tearing of the muscle you can
even use it to develop explosiveness
ballistic isometrics a form of
overcoming isometric where you're
basically pushing explosively or pulling
explosively without moving so that might
sound like a contradiction but it's the
explosive intent and as you're doing
these movements make sure you're still
breathing through them a typical mistake
is to hold your breath as you push and
this is one of the actual benefits of
using overcoming isometrics it's the
perfect opportunity to practice
breathing through maximal exertion
another tip is to build up to this take
your time and listen to your body this
is intensive and if you get the wrong
movement you could easily pull something
strain something or even pass out from
exertion so build up to it slowly it's a
really useful skill a really useful tool
once you get the hang of it but make
sure you've got experience with these
movements first and don't go held to
leather right away so i hope you found
this video useful interesting guys if
you did then please leave a like and
share around that would help me out
immensely let me know in the comments
down below if overcoming isometrics is
something that you would use in your own
training and whether you think that this
was a big part of what made bruce lee so
special in terms of his physique and his
performance if you like using alternate
training methods to build a body that's
not just strong and aesthetic but mobile
fast balanced then you might enjoy my
ebook and training program super
functional training there's a link to
that description down below i also have
a print book functional training and
beyond which you can find on amazon
which is a guide and introduction to
functional training subscribe if you
want to see more like this hit the bell
button if you want notifications either
way thank you so much for watching this
one guys and i'll see you next time
bye for now